a seven-month-old baby is dead in san
francisco
because the district attorney refused to
do his job
because the narrative that now exists is
that any use of police force
is evil and wrong that that
going after criminals is somehow unjust
because the criminals they didn't choose
to become criminals
they're just it's the systemic racist
injustice patriarchy white supremacy
toxic it's everybody's fault but their
own
you know now thank goodness we're living
in a consequence culture
as lavar burton says and that and in
this consequence culture
all the criminals get to go free even
the republicans are endorsing this kind
of nonsense
it was it was the most misguided action
of the trump campaign
or of the trump administration rather i
thought trump did such great stuff huge
fan of the president
former president now i guess i have to
say but he
focused so much time and energy on what
on springing people out of the clink
why why would we do that when did
republicans
become the party of springing criminals
out of the clink you know what happens
when you spread
spring criminals from the clink more
people suffer
chaser boudin i don't know how to
pronounce this guy's name
he is a radical district attorney in san
francisco
elected not that long ago jason boudin
with his lax policies allowed
a guy with a long rap sheet to get out
of the clink
he was already booked on domestic
violence but hey
come you know it's just not fair because
disproportionately
men of certain communities are targeted
the the argument is that black men are
targeted in fact
criminals are being targeted by the
criminal justice system if there's some
overlap there that's a coincidence i
guess
that's not not the primary motivator so
okay you let the guy
out on all these cockamamie racial
theories
what happens kills a seven month old kid
where is the consequence for that guy
okay now
now he'll go back to jail i hope i guess
where's the accountability where's the
justice where are the crocodile tears
from the oscars stage
what about this compassionate wonderful
district attorney
for prison reform we do need prison
reform in this country we need to put
more criminals in prison for longer and
they need to face stiffer consequences
i don't think that anybody can look
around at the last year and a half
as the country is going up cities being
torched every other night
and say you know you know the problem in
this country we don't have enough
criminals on the streets
we need to let criminals out of prison i
don't think so i don't think that's the
problem
hold up do not go anywhere you need to
stay here
not forever just until you smash that
button
and you like and you subscribe and you
make sure that you never miss a video
from us
because youtube some of you messaged me
about this yesterday
there's been some shenanigans with my
show okay and i'm not saying what
just some weird stuff irregularities
make sure that you are getting
notifications every single time see you
[Music]
next
[Music]
you